hopefully by then we'll we'll have
actual in-person meetups yeah that'd be
great
I didn't have you know completely
settled for just virtual meet up so that
you can know I like I very much miss the
real setup I was thinking with the only
thing we need now is really a venue
where we can fit like 70 80 people with
one-and-a-half meters distance and then
we can have a meetup from the tourists
there is no number of people restriction
right yeah my my new employer may be
able to help with that yeah and we are
live on YouTube now by the way so just
letting you know do we have people on
YouTube watching and you see that
yeah okay since we have no other topic
to talk about right now I'm going back
to the classical weather do you really
think this weekend it's gonna be rainy
last weekend it light and we didn't plan
and it was sad do I really think this
weekend is gonna be rainy we've planned
we've planned a kind of a whole fist in
the house for Saturday so I think
Saturday the where there's gonna be
lovely if you look at the weather report
I mean it's less of a question of what
do I see and more a question of well
what does the forecast say I don't know
I mean if we're lucky there's a I don't
know there's someone with a with a
background in meteorology here I think
it actually is debate that much better
than I can yeah when I was in Vancouver
our estimate was that random like an
algorithm giving round the map will
probably better than 4kd test that no
but it was always wrong anyway when were
you in Vancouver in 1960s almost ten
years ago okay
yeah I don't know I'm tempted to make a
comment about the great speed of
progress with machine learning and all
that but I noticed just today that
there's a I don't know if people are
familiar with the hugging phase pi torch
library for various different NLP tasks
a notice that there's a I didn't count
that but I scrolled through like pages
and pages of model file names the group
at the University of Helsinki who does
computational linguistics they've
released machine translation models for
like I must be like a hundred different
language pairs so that's fun I'm gonna
be translating some Finnish in the
future automatically yeah I tried that I
tried that already like I just did a
couple of like quick tests translating
Finnish into English it was okay it was
like the English was still
understandable and it sort of it was
pretty accurate it was a pretty accurate
representation of what was what what the
Finnish sentence was or the paragraph I
feel like you're setting a really low
bar for machine translation okay I mean
you're the you're the NLP person maybe
that's just like what you expect but I
expect to be able to have a conversation
with people when I use machine
translation and like that not sound
funny yeah I think you should be less
worried about sounding funny and more
worried about sort of that's a strophic
misunderstanding
oh I'd like the funniest thing I
actually encountered was we had a
customer a spanish-speaking customer in
I think Central America and another Ana
spanish-speaking employee and the voice
was I think it was like why zoom so the
voice was transcribed and translated
into English and you read that and you
would understand like very well what the
customers saying you could not
understand what the employee says so I
don't know if it was like the the
English transcription from different
accents different but like it had some
translated thing it was probably like a
different Spanish dialogue keep in mind
that in Mexico you have 66 different
languages that are similar some of these
don't later Mexico okay okay so it might
be sound like Spanish or similar but
because of dialect or something it's
good it might be dipped or different I
mean one one problem that I always have
in evaluating the the machine
translations especially from finish to
any language but finished in English
mostly is that I I tend to read the
English translation with knowledge of
what the finish original said and then I
kind of read in some interpret or like
it's very difficult for me to judge how
much I'm reading into the translation
and how someone who doesn't who's not a
native Finnish speaker how much would
they actually understand of the
translate the text yeah but but often
it's like you know you read the
translation and you go like yeah it you
can make a good we'll sort of guess on
what what the what was actually said but
it's not it's not poetry and it's not
quite even at the level of like here's
some prose
this is the same of Hungarian because
you can garner any finish on in the same
group of languages I guess yeah but I
don't speak Hungarian I have no idea
what they what anyone who speaks
Hungarian is saying so my god
there is a really interesting aspect
with like Finnish Finnish and Estonian
are also very closely related and
there's a lot of words that are very
that are shared but have different
meanings it's the same word it just
means different thing when you talk
about Estonian this is where I have to
join yeah very good
but that very very often throws me off
good like with us I mean I don't speak
Estonian either but but I understand
like I don't know 15 percent of the
words but then I understand them wrong
because they mean a different thing in
Estonia and then then that same word
wouldn't finish yeah this is the word
hernia in an Estonian that means
something bad in Finnish hernia means
hernia but you speak it in different way
yeah yeah yeah I mean okay I would love
to talk about language for the entire
duration but I guess that might get a
little bit boring for others
participating so it's it's almost five
past seven and I guess we can I guess we
can start
so welcome everyone to the June 2020 PI
data virtual Meetup this is now what are
we fourth fourth virtual meet up already
I think so we're getting better at doing
this the meetup that is happening in the
room is also being live streamed to
YouTube and I believe we have at least
some number of people also watching the
YouTube stream it seems that we have 45
people watching YouTube stream at the
moment okay so and we have two speakers
Carol and unless I'm gonna avoid saying
the last names because I cannot say the
last name of the first speaker in any
kind of a meaningful way so Carol Andrus
and we're gonna have a little break in
between what we have done in the past
with questions is if you're on the zoom
meeting you can I don't know write your
question down or write the question in
the chat if it's a longer one if it's a
yes/no answer from the first speaker
then he said that he's happy to just
deal with it right away but we'll try to
save all the questions to the end and
then go through those if you're watching
the YouTube live stream there is a chat
in the YouTube on the on the live stream
page you can write your questions in the
chat and we have Misha moderating the
YouTube chat and then he's gonna try to
pass those questions onto the onto the
zoom call the YouTube live stream I
believe is about 10 or 15 seconds
there's a 10 or 15 second delay so that
may cause some issues and okay that's
pretty much everything I wanted to say
to begin with but if
for Earth I give way to our first
speaker there's one thing I I need to I
want just share my screen because I want
to show something but I need to okay I
can't share my screen because I need to
quit zoom and do all kinds of things
with the privacy settings here okay so
there is a PI data global meet up for a
conference that is being planned the
website for that is live since I don't
know two hours ago something like that
so if you go to global dot pi dot org
you will find more details about the
conference there it is a virtual
conference that is happening in four
different time zones simultaneously
there will be an open call for proposals
the CFP is not yet live but we are
hoping to get it live very soon too so
if you just monitor if you can if you're
on Twitter you can follow PI data or PI
data Berlin on Twitter or you can just
keep refreshing the website to see when
the the CFP is open but it should happen
within the next week okay that's all I
want to say about that
each other don't forget the challenge Oh
a challenge right right so we have a
challenge did have we sent out the
stickers do you know the last time last
month
no one's more familiar with that but
I've known okay we'll ask Noah about the
details when she joins a little later um
so there's a challenge who is the
farthest away joining the meeting Jim is
a pretty good contender are you in
Allston at the moment Austin Texas
United States you okay Austin Texas but
I'm pretty
sure there's gonna be someone old
further away so if your again if you're
in the zoom call just post your sort of
rough location and our country and city
should be enough on the chat if you're
on the YouTube channel same thing and we
will the the person who is how did we do
this direct flight distance I think we
just did the Great Circle distance on
the earth Great Circle business page
distance from to.net okay don't tell
them that that's gonna they're gonna go
there and cheat
okay I'm not using that yeah yeah so the
person who's the farthest away from
Berlin Germany we will send you some
potato stickers so yes definitely worth
participating right okay I'm in Berlin
Germany me too oh yeah close maybe maybe
next time we do who's closest right okay
sorry I'm gonna stop talking now Carol
please go ahead
all right thank you thank you thank you
for the introduction so I will talk
about skin cancer today so a very
serious topic I hope you can see my
slides now so I will show you some
computer vision methods but in general I
will talk about skin cancer how to
approach this topic of skin cancer
machine and computer vision because this
is what I'm doing for I don't know
thirteen years now so skin cancer
analysis but before that let me just
introduce myself so my name is Carol
crystal ski yes it's a very hard name to
pronounce and well when I when I'm
working what I'm doing I'm doing machine
learning for about let's say 15 years
more last I even obtained a PhD in this
topic at the iodine University
specializing in skin cancer so health
haltech not only I actually did the PG
teases is about skin cancer but I'm also
doing different projects in the area of
health tech and now I'm the CTO in the
founder of a company for ten years now
that is actually also doing so someone
else's in this topic work foot work I
have experience in different kind of
areas like Stanford University for
example where we have develop and asked
the solution to go stand for currently
the covered case that we actually also
analyzing data forward for the carbon
discovery and different kind of
different kind of companies some of
these are actually also from Berlin
alright that's a short introduction what
is the current state of melanoma
melanoma
what's melanoma actually did time
the level of this presentation is very
very basic so I will try to explain all
of the well hard hard words potentially
like melanoma is the skin cancer one of
the skin cancer there are several
different skin cancers malignant
melanoma is one of it and this this is
one of the most most dangerous skin
cancer so what are what is the current
state so what is the what is the
probability we would like to solve so
the problem is not really replacing the
doctors the medical doctors the GPS and
any agnostic so the goal is to support
the medical doctors what I'm saying
about the problem because because some
of my research now what what we are
doing now we are commercializing this
solution so we are we are we are trying
to push it to the market to make it
available for the doctors not only for
research but also for for the doctors to
yeah to put potentially reduce but you
increase that curacy increase the
sensitivity increase increased
specificity so increase the quality of
the diagnostic of the medical doctors
and there are different solution how to
solve it one of the most basic one is
actually to find out if on the image you
have it's a skin cancer and melanoma or
maybe that's it's something else it's
not really it's it's an illness but or
some case it is not really
malignant so it's a binary distinguished
problem that binary classification or
what we can also do we can actually have
a multi-class problem we actually we
would like to differentiate or try to
find different kind of illnesses and
including melanoma so mehram is not the
most popular skin illness when it comes
to the moles but it's the most dangerous
so obviously we would like to keep a
focus on that but we would like to also
find out if there is if we have if the
mole is something different all what we
can also do we can employ
one of the men was colouring matters a
scarring metal is um it's a matter used
by the doctors to find out if it's a
cancer or not they just go through some
some metrics I will explain it later
during the presentation I would give you
some some kind of medical knowledge to
share with you some medical öitís while
I explain it so the scarring metal is
something that it's a matter that the
doctors use to find out if it's a cancer
or not in the head they take take some
of their features that are visible on
the image or the last solution is to
find patterns what does it mean there
are some specific patterns of melanoma
different illnesses different moles not
only melanoma and you can find out and
try to figure out if it's if it's a
malignant case or not well when I
started my my my research in skin cancer
at the University so many many years ago
in 2007 so 30 years ago I asked one of
my colleague at university to share the
data set ah the moles that he actually
had and he gave me 47 47 images so you
can imagine 47 images it's not really
it's nothing ready to do any kind of
research and this is what was this was
the situation thirteen years ago now you
have different kind of datasets the most
popular is I see which act includes that
hum 10000 data set as well
it has about 34,000 images of different
moles that's a huge data set ten years
ago it wasn't really possible to get
such a data set it's really going in
moving in the girl in the right
direction and when it comes to the
availability of data and it's public you
can download it and do to your research
on melanoma and even I as I see is
publishing challenges like Kaggle is
doing it so Carol also publishing
challenges is SES dedicated to melanoma
and every year there was a child
as a competition to find out different
kind of cases it's not only about
strictly Manoa there's there are some
image pre-processing challenges as well
and that's now it's available so what I
did having just less than 50 images I
asked several institutions
dermatologists to share the data set and
finally I received a dataset of 5,000
images tonight based on doing my PhD
with 5000 is enough it's not enough to
actually do a potentially it's not
really enough to do deep narrow Network
but it's good to do they're shallow
methods implemented shallow methods
using this kind the size of data set
with 34,000 images that you have on is I
see it's easy to do any kind of medal I
will show you one of the solution that
is already and it was a the winner of
the challenge from 2019 oh it's loading
yeah
it's loading okay that way so the
competitions on the MoMA melanoma it
started 2016 so actually after one year
before I before I finished my PhD the
cause mostly in 2016 2017 2018 we're
about the segmentation feature
extraction classification because the
data said it wasn't such so big like it
was now it was about five thousand about
one thousand it actually increased each
year now we have thirty four thousand
the last challenge was not all not about
feature extraction but it was about
classification not a binary
classification was about multi-class
classification for nine different
illnesses there are more indices so skin
illnesses so we have a multi-class
problem we have different with nine
classes which is quite complex but
that's that's that's really nice and
just here you have a the ROC curve which
doesn't give better understanding how
good we aren't finding different kind of
illnesses you see melanoma here with
Melba the blue is here the chart mark so
we are not not yet there right to find
to be perfect on finding this skin
cancer the most most the most dangerous
skin cancer right because there are
different kind of cancers and different
kind of illnesses not all of them are
cancers and you see there are some
unknown cases there are it's almost
random right so we are still not there
most of the solution that we apply to
this challenge based on convolution
neural network to find patterns based on
the images what is important to mention
is that the data set that is here I as I
see is based on typical classic their
mother mattes copy images I will explain
you later what's the difference between
our multi-level and their Matassa mattes
copy one level image but we can see that
actually is increasing the number of
research papers this one is it's based
on science direct.com and you see that
the number of papers published in the
topic of melanoma and artificial
intelligence it's increasing it's not
coming in thousands but if you go to
challenge to is I see challenge the most
of the most of the results of the teams
that actually published the results they
have also published a paper on it so
that if you can combine science director
springer with all of the other
publishers the numbers in should be one
much much bigger but you see it's is
it's growing it's growing in the last
year especially now when we have the
covered and we would like to automate
and many many actions many procedures
that you do obviously we cannot
ultimately talk totally still and be a
person behind it
to tear taking ignores
so that's that's that's the current
state one of the challenges in my
opinion there are two big challenges
that I think we will focus in the next
year we should support general
practitioners so that medical doctors
that they're not not specced specialized
in dermatology so it means that general
medical doctors and I mean for more
typical illnesses I don't really have a
specialty in dermatology so they are not
really good at finding skin cancer you
can imagine that the sensitivity of such
doctors is something between 50 and 60
percent so that's quite low and a
challenge here is to find a solution
that will support this kind of challenge
in this kind of GPS - well to find out
to increase the sensitivity specificity
and obviously accuracy of GPS because it
because the the medical doctor said my
thermal charges the specialize in skin
cancer they can reach even 80 85 % of
sensitivity which is quite high and the
second challenge that I think that we
have that will come in the next next
year is to detect men of no more not
only on the skin because melanoma is a
cancer that doesn't it's not well only
on skin it can happen on eyes or on the
nails which is much more difficult to
find all you have also kind of special
kind of skin cancer that is transparent
look you can imagine how hard it is to
find a cancer if it's transparent right
so that's a that's a challenging task
for for the researchers also for the
doctors for the Medical ducts all right
so I will talk about a bit because we
want to we want to approach get
get to the market with the solution and
if you deal with any kind of health tech
product or solution you will probably
face the problem of FDA requirement and
getting well getting being approved with
your solution to the market it's more
about this is more like more like a
lawyer stuff but just just few slides
and I would like to explain if that's
something that we are now facing so if
you have a I solution that is supporting
the doctors you need to get an FDA
approval or the same action in Europe
but in general you cannot just use it on
the market market you can you need to
have an approval to get to the market
it's regulated and it's called in u.s.
it's called it 510 K Proteus
it's - you need to get this kind of this
kind of approval - to go to the market
and usually and actually and not all but
actually almost all cases it comes with
a medical device so it's not just a
software it's coming with the medical
device and it's sold also as a medical
device and the FDA regulation they tell
us that on a website
it takes up to 90 days to get to get
approval to be honest it doesn't work
like that actually usually takes about
six months to get to approval I guess
they have many questions in the meantime
and and they will ask for more details
on the algorithm so I will tell you some
more about how to prepare for this kind
of approvals well and the biggest
challenge here is the clinical
evaluation so you need to find out if
your solution so si MD is the short name
for our software as a medical device so
it's a AI I mean machine learning
solution that comes together with a
medical device like our mo they're my
mother's cup for example which is the
most basic device for the doctors that
they are using to
for the diagnosis and the clinical part
can take even up to two years to find
out if your solution really is is able
to increase accuracy and yeah you have
three stages here so we have to do well
but in general its takes takes a lot of
time to really do this part and it it
needs to you need to involve also the
dermatologist in this phase and also
obviously patients that will use your
solution so the whole process is very
difficult I will not do you have some
sources so we I can send you the link
oh you will have you will get the
presentation so you can check the links
here go to the FDA webpage you to find
out how it works but in general its it's
written the document that they provide
is written in a way that it's very hard
to well it's written well but it's very
hard to what's good machine learning
practices right it's it's a charity
using document and obviously we also ask
us data scientists as machine learning
experts we know what what are the good
practices but still that's not enough
then what they want to have no I mean
FDA and what you need to think about
from the beginning is to have the models
explainable so they need to be
explainable and obviously if you do our
modification right then you also need to
have an acceptance so let's say you're
going to do a retraining of Lamanna and
it takes also time to make sorry for the
quality of this image that's something I
download from TM f you see we see an
increase in numbers when it comes to the
AI machine learning solutions introduced
in different kind of areas not only in
the dermatology not only in and skin
cancer the different kind of different
kind of areas in medicine that were
actually it is use and is approved I
mean there Bev da approved the so-called
artificial intelligence based algorithms
okay so um oh that's that's the missing
image here that I have here right yeah
the mission the missing image I don't
see here but I have it in slide for now
and when it comes to the skin cancer
there are two companies having an FDA
approval one is from Germany and they
are called full finder and they have and
they have an FDA approval approval for
convolutional neural network as you know
convolution a convolution neural network
is explainable so they are able to do to
do it and the second car company and out
that's called Canfield I don't know
really what method they use because they
only announce it that they use a I buy
that didn't saw it work in practice so
it's very hard to say but they say that
they are using it and there are more
more companies that will get an FDA
approval probably soon like hina for
example also a German company that
probably will also introduce our machine
learning solution and what is important
here are explainable artificial
intelligence metals and what time would
like to tell you here is just go through
very very shortly because the main part
computing part comes in a minute that
you should focus when you do a
healthcare project you should focus on
explainable not as my name explaining
explained earlier they are Metis so
interpretable artificial intelligence
responsible artificial intelligence and
there are different kind of
characteristic of explainable AI but in
general understandability comprehensible
digital in other words whatever you
develop you should think about the map
in the model in a way that it should be
explainable understandable by a human
being not only by a abide by the method
or by I don't data scientist it should
be explainable and that's very important
to include into the FDA process and also
interpretable explainable
as well and transfer they're very
important
characteristic of their important topic
the transparency so what's going on in
there and they're free different levels
or different ways how we can make the
model transparent so the first one we
can simulate the protest as a human
being and the meaning we can set it for
example as a set of rules to go through
and actually give it to a human to go
through it's easy to explain and it's
also easy to be approved by the FDA but
it's very hard to develop really good
models that are totally simulator ball
to choose that that you can able to
simulate the poll process and it's very
hard to find such a models to to be good
when it comes to accuracy the second
level is the composability it means we
can decompose we can find out get the
whole model you compose into a few
different parts and it's try to explain
each of the two parts separately or at
least the most important one for example
if you have a narrow Network you can try
to explain a part of it like the
convolution neural network right you
don't need to explain all of the weights
that you have but at least you should
explain the main idea what's behind I
will show you an example in a minute how
to do it
Oh algorithm transparency transparency
so it's not only it's not it's not only
about simulating it but it's we have for
example equation it is usually it's as
simple it's a linear model usually like
a linear regression for example where
it's easy to reproduce the whole process
so it's not a set of rules it's not
exactly easy to read to do a simulation
I mean okay in case of linear erection
it is but there are some others that are
linearized are not so easy to to
simulate but it's easy to use the
equations to make it explain a more like
for example as VM might be one of it
so there are many reasons how why to use
explaining AI for us the most important
thing is obviously the regulatory
agencies to to be compliant and be able
to sell the product at the end with with
the hardware so we are not producing the
hardware this Li as a company we are we
are building a machine learning solution
for that but obviously also explainable
I is and one of the way how we can also
debug why it happens like that and there
are many many failures in the cases of
failures where machine learning models
failed and explainable AI might be one
of the solution to explain why it
happened like that so the goals there
are different kind of course obviously
of an explainable either I like we want
to have a robust clear clear
understandable model that is
understandable by the main experts right
but also what is important we don't want
to know what's the importance of the
features for example right so there are
also different other other goals like
informative news confidential
we want to know what's actually
information behind it or even transfer
it to our different to a different the
case right or even interact with it you
you probably have heard about some cases
like the Thai chat board a tweet board
or you have probably heard about the
case about about the gorillas with in
Google that's something that is not
really for and that's also one of the
goal to have a model that is it has an
well keep the privacy but also this is
for all for the users that it's the day
that use this model so there are
different ways how to explain it how to
make the explanation for FDA as well so
text explanation is the
is one for us the researchers using
formulas equations symbols tax that's
easy for people who are not really good
in math or doesn't understand what was
in the back and in many cases the visual
explanation is a better one to visual
visualize for example for a chart with a
plot how is how does it work in the back
Oh local explanation so take just a part
of the whole problem and let's say if
you have a skin cancer so we can take
just for example one layer or off the
image and try to explain it just based
on that I will show you also one example
here in a minute or explain my example
like putting some some different images
like cancer non cancer and what is
happening with with the data on the
input during the whole process or
simplify for example if it's too complex
if it's too complex we can build a model
there's a simplified version of the
complex one and try to explained during
in this way all the future relevance
that's the most basic one to find out
what are the features that a has action
impact on the model okay so why not the
case is here this is the melanoma here
you have two images you can imagine
which one of these is our cancer right
one on the left or one was right so in
this case I know because I studied this
topic for a force at least a few years
it's obviously the one on the left here
so this one here is a cancer case why
because it has some dots here you have
it's not regular and so on and also the
doctor the medical doctors that will do
their analysis they will also focus on
some factors like the dots here it's
called episode the dots it means that
actually it's going deep into the skin
into the blood vessels and that's
dangerous also to hear the black black
stripes here it's also know
really it's also pattern is specific for
cancer this one here on the right it
looks on the first look like um well not
the previous one but this one is not a
cancer this just one is on the cancer
it's quite regular here we have kind of
a net here I'm surrounded and a black
part of in the middle but that's not
that's not a cancer and using computer
vision we can we can or machine learning
or pre-processing metals image free
process and we can find out this kind of
patterns and find out if it's if it's a
cancer or not but also there are also
some cases where I'm giving here IBM
because I have developed they have
developed a solution in the past that
was about giving predicted giving giving
advices for for for the patients and
actually failed totally fade with with
with the advice that they gave by the
out with automated solution using some
machine airing methods behind it and so
it's not always good to there are some
cases where actually you can find out it
doesn't work so well so we need to be
aware that that's why also deaf yes he
used to really check what's going on
behind so white box model again these
are the models that car easy explainable
so we have the input we have some let's
say a decision tree you know exactly
what's the rule are we know what's in it
and we no doubt but like for example a
linear regression it's easy to interpret
that's easy to explain even for a person
who doesn't know what's a linear
regression right and that's one of the
matter that you can use for for your
model for your case if you're doing a
healthcare and but obviously in a
direction it isn't really so useful in
this case so you can use different trees
or you can use also SVM for example
right and obviously what's what's the
what's the
I mentioned already so we would like to
have an information about the importance
of the features or how two features
affect the prediction for example or
understand the big picture of the whole
whole thing and there are also other
other ways where why we shoot or what
case interaction we can we can use
explainable I to debug the model to
improve some of the features engineering
process and many many other cases like
eliminating overfitting for example like
debugging we can find leaks data leaks
or validation / strategies for example
all right so feature engineering feature
using that's something that is makes
sense for shallow metals because we use
usually a deep narrow Network and
usually it's not something that we just
give the image as the input so we will
not really get their features out of it
instead of that the network will try to
give us information about the features
like in the convolution Network
comparing to white box you have to also
black box mathematical actually you know
exactly what's in it it means you have a
method that you are not able to explain
let me show you
okay that's G sparrows are logistic
regression k-means the student trees
these are actually easy to explain like
the SVM for example so let me show you
one notebook you have also notebooks
available on the github repository let
me show you the difference between the
black box matter and the white part I
hope you see my you see my screen now so
the black box now this is a very easy
very simple neural network with just
three layers here some free dense layers
with a dermis the optimizer - realm
functions and one softmax obviously at
the end and we are fitting in with
Kara's here but if we would like to
explain what's one what is the meaning
of the weights here you this is how you
can print weights from a layer this and
this
it's the second layer you will get
something like that
that's not something you can really
explain there are too many weights even
in such a not really deep network
because we have only three layers it's
not so easy to explain so there are
matters how to explain it so make it
explainable even on narrow network that
is not explainable in the first in the
first look obviously have also the white
box matters like the decision tree for
example and you will even if you're not
three especially if you don't really
have experience in machine learning
having such a such information such a
visualization like that if you know
what's x2 x3 if you change it to the
feature name and if you don't know
really what's the what's the Gini index
you still are able to find out what's
here how to actually move from a tree to
a set of rules that are that we are able
to assimilate or go through and actually
get the prediction so that's a white box
white-box medals not all decision trees
are a white box manners first
I mean decision - yes but random forest
it depends on the level of complexity it
might be considered as a white box or
black box method so in case of health
check like we have here
we usually should use a shallow metal or
axe explainable method if it's a neural
net like this one we will talk about we
need to add some explainable AI and
method to explained and there are
different kind of methods to explain
them the models you have built obviously
if it's a shallow method it's if it's a
linear method then it's easy you need to
actually use any kind of explainable
metals to to to make it explainable
because it is already explainable it is
something that you can use directly but
there are a few groups one of the
database on the future influence on the
on the on the result on the output or
explaining just directly the output
what's
what's on output what does it mean and
so on
oh the neural network feature extraction
that is a commonly no well known matters
in convolutional neural networks okay I
don't see any questions so far
oh there are two all right and so
there's one really nice book on
unexplainable yeah I will not go through
all of the matters because we don't have
time enough time but yeah few like like
the PDP plots or Shapley values or scope
rules online if you if you use the pipe
to python package tool package
management tool you will find out that
actually for all of these metals here
you have a separate library to do that
you can use directly to find out to
explain your model so line for example
or sharp it's already implemented just
to give you one example how does it look
like here's an example from from the
from this book here that i can recommend
you for explainable AI that you can use
for example what's the what's the
influence from temperature humidity and
wind speed on the number of souls bikes
for example right so you can find out
just drawing this kind of applause it's
actually limited because we are kind of
limited to numb you are a number of
features like two or three dimensions i
can add no not anymore so that's that's
the limitation but on the other hand is
very easy to interpret this kind of hot
chart so i'm try to base on the features
and now what's the impact of each
feature to on the prediction not on the
correlation can be used there are some
more sophisticated like to actually try
to find inches so try to line them to
try to find them trying to find
distinguish between oh you know what's
nice now try to find all this causes
that's why i find positive or negative
cases and try to explain things of that
output so it's also easy to Pratt
many many times I said that's my heavy G
computer plus it's one of the methods
was the noise in the audio and now yes
it's alright
sorry okay let me go back I'll shop
limit values that's a combination of
different kind of different kind of
features what if we change the number of
features and do different kind of
combinations it might give us a better
understanding it's a better
understanding what what is the impact
and that's the metal is called Shapley
values do to get a better understanding
what of the combination of the features
to get a better understanding of the
impact have you compute easy to explain
clear all the camp write a class
activation map using convolution nerado
so convolution error why they are widely
used also in melanoma it's because it's
easy to understand what is the output so
we actually calculate a gradient on the
lat one of the last one of the last
layer to find out where actually with
what features or what part of the image
has the biggest impact on on the
prediction at the end so that's
something we how we can explain the
convolution error and we generate a heat
map that if you combine it with the
original image we will get something
like that and for the classification
that's on that's done actually on image
that if you get the prediction like
Golden Retriever which is true you will
find out oh ok so the ear the nose here
a bit maybe did I hear the chest that's
what what has the biggest impact on the
classification the prediction and if you
have a different kind of dog or
different kind of cat you see that there
are different kind of areas where the
importance so different kind of areas
where we find out that the collusion
they're not a final okay that's that's
here's a pattern here is something that
that is specific for the maltese bar
dogs or the smallpox and so on okay so
what I'm I know I don't have too much
time what what is the proposed solution
that we I'm implementing we implementing
now we use that's that's what you get if
you go to the isic database you will get
only this kind of images so a typical
their matter scope image a regular image
which is actually an image that we get
using a well typical wavelength of light
so the visible wavelength of light what
what we can do and this is what we also
do we provide more than just one image
based on different wavelengths of light
and based on that the skin is actually
reacting differently and we get more
images quiet the calligrapher call again
for example or the hemoglobin so we can
extract much much more features from
this kind of images because one mole
means five images and we can go it's not
really a multi-layer because it's not
really exactly the skin doesn't is not
really built from you know exactly
layers like here it's more like there
are kind of a it's more like more
complex structure but there are some
blood vessels or hemoglobin here's
colligan here inside the melanin that
you have in the skin and each of these
kind of cells oh yeah cells they it's
reacting differently to different
wavelengths of light so that's what we
do and what we do we automate the
scarring methods that are used by the
doctors so you have different kind of
scarring metals there are plenty of
these car metals metals 20 years ago
there was what there was only ABCD now
it's ABCDE so a symmetry border color
and it was diameter now it's
differential structures and E it's the
evolution how the mold changed in time
and there are different different other
other metals that are used by the doctor
to find out if this is a cancer or not
the scoring value they will just find if
it's a not not a skin cancer a
suspicious one always definitely our
cancer so you so they said also the
priority should be make something with
it or not really and what we do we we
automate the whole process so now we
have out made the hunters call I will
show you in a minute how we do it we
have also the seven checkpoint list
almost done the ABCD not naughty because
that we don't have such data set to
recover II but ABCD is already covered
and some some of the other metals as
well he have some examples of patterns
that we analyzed so here the brain the
brain pattern which is a pattern that
say oh that's not a cancer in most case
it's not a cancer
here you have their blood blue Vale here
it's kind of a black luke pattern and
this means it's a very advanced cancer
all you have here the dots here that's
also advanced cancer and this these
images are done with different
wavelengths of light I mean these two
are the same one these are different one
and also here this one is a combination
of three other ones so this is actually
how deep is going into the skin
okay so to the demo and I'm done so in a
pre-processing demo and let me show you
some of the examples here that you have
arranged Kara let me very quickly jump
in here you you can either do the demo
and no questions or you can go straight
to questions but I'm afraid we're out of
time and we need to then move on but
I'll leave the decision up to you if you
want you'd rather take questions or
rather do the demo one minute demo two
minutes questions okay okay so here's
the demo it's easy you can find out it
on the github it's easy to find out the
image here it's on really nice cancer
you see the blue
stuff here are assaults around it's
really advanced and if you go into other
the other mm notebooks that I have
shared with you you can use some of the
metals that are also here explain we use
different kinds for example we can use
this histogram here to find out how many
blue colors act is actually on this
image for example right or even use
ultra encoders here to find out here you
can see okay that's that's fine because
it's more blue it's more red and blue
that's that's good
but if it would be more blue than it
means oh it's not really how it should
look like right and obviously we can use
different different different models of
of of color alright so what we do there
are four different four different
notebooks you can go through and check
the really basic image pre-processing
methods that are useful for getting the
actually the ABC covered ABC the ABC
method is caramel what you also do we
also do use fractal methods to find out
the borders for example here right you
can see it's it's quite fine compared to
this one right so we use those a fractal
metals to find out the border for
example all the shape of this specific
pattern and that's how we do the whole
image pre-processing to get the features
outside instead of a convolution neural
network to find out the patterns we have
more than 30 different patterns to to
that you should cover or we should cover
in the whole process now we have used
SVM and decision trees we also use
convolutional neural networks but the
neural networks in general that are
quite hard to explain so we for now
a typical not convolutional network so
we don't really use it for now for the
FDA approval some of the papers that I
would like you to show that you can read
some of them and I have published and
some of the some of research papers like
expert system of applications find it on
internet adding my name character
Starsky and skin cancer and Google you
will
several papers you can read it about
skin cancer how to analyze it yeah
humanly that's that's this is the part
where you can ask questions that was a
little bit more than one minute demo
there's one question that I thought was
quite relevant given the amount of time
that you spend on the FDA part so this
is a question and what the what's the
level of explained ability needed by the
FDA mm-hmm you can you should think
about persons well you can usually think
about the people from the FDA and they
don't need to be experts right in health
care even they might be but you should
think about them like explaining them
like it was like it would be your I
don't know your uncle that is not really
our medical doctor to explain step by
step what's going on in a way that the
person will say oh yeah I understand how
this work how it does work so I'm fine
with it so there is you can use one of
the metals explainable a explainable
metals that I show to you before to make
it you know to go from step by step and
there was a lot of documentation behind
it so don't think that it's just one
sentence to two or just one page to
explain it's really in many many cases
is just many pages that you need to
write to explain it visually text and so
on okay so then let's thank Carol I
don't know I guess we virtually clap and
thank Carol for the presentation the
links to the notebooks that he was
showing are available on the meetup page
if you go to meetup.com and search for
friday to berlin go to the June meetup
you'll find the links there and now
we're gonna take a little break but we
will not cut the YouTube stream we have
a program number for the for the break
and for that I yield the floor to Noah
and tail and I believe also Jim yes hi
everyone we decided to try this meat up
a different structure for the lecture
for the break where we are gonna have
some short conversations or
presentations from about PI data and I'm
focusing about a community that we have
here and maybe you can also if you have
questions write them in the chat oh and
then maybe we'll give you the floor to
speak and have more of a conversation
we're gonna start with the presentation
of nom focus what it is and how does PI
data and PI data but lean fit Center is
from Jim who is in this far far away
United States not before the farthest
the way though it would be a little bit
of a shade to send Jim's on pi day yeah
yeah no we don't need that I have more
than of stickers to keep me busy for a
while
exactly if you want to try to claim
stickers of course please send us an
e-mail to info at PI data dot building
with your location and if you're lucky
enough you and after the short
presentation from Jim we'll head tell
would have a conversation we threw a
fight a Tamilian organizers yeah and
please feel free to write down questions
and it will give you the opportunity to
ask them yeah so Jim the screen is yours
I guess yeah awesome I will share my
screen you see that
but yeah more to the point I can you see
it should say don't focus on PI data
alright we good yeah we see that okay so
yeah thanks thanks for inviting me I am
always happy for the chance to talk
about PI data and then focus and
particularly that's for those I probably
unfortunately having to be able to meet
a lot of you and would have loved to
meet you in person at a Berlin
conference this year and unfortunately I
was not so happy to meet you virtually
my name is Jim Weiss
I am the num focus Events Manager and
people understandably after wonder like
what's the relationship between PI data
and num focus or you know even what the
heck is num focus and so here's just a
quick overview and happy to answer any
questions afterwards but no focus is
it's a nonprofit organization we are
located in Austin Texas in the United
States which seems to be one of the
further distances from this meetup but
glad is not be for this distance so that
we can give out more stickers and you
know I always joked that focus is more
than just a sticker company you know we
we we have a couple of key missions that
I'm happy to talk about here that
includes but is not limited to giving
out a lot of different stickers for your
laptops so our mission focuses on two
main areas one we directly sponsored 35
open-source projects and scientific
computer programming and that number is
always growing and these projects a lot
of people know and use like pandas and
Jupiter and numpy and scipy matplotlib
okay and you actually see the full list
here and I liked you to take a look and
see how many of these projects you
recognize indoor use some are widely
used some are used some kind of like
niche sectors but are still vitally
important to the work being done and so
that that's kind of
our one focus of a mission is directly
sponsoring these projects here and the
second part of our mission is to support
the community of users and developers of
those open-source tools and that's where
PI data come in comes in PI data is a
program of non focus the mission of Pi
data is to provide a forum for the
community and users to learn from one
another we do this in a couple ways each
year we host conferences all around the
world PI data or PI data Berlin is one
of our flagship conferences it's one of
our biggest but we also have conferences
across Europe in America South America
Asia and we're always looking to expand
to new areas and of course everyone here
is aware we also host PI data meetups
and we currently have one hundred and
seventy three different meetups from
across the globe in 61 different
countries that are all organized and run
by volunteers from the community so very
very important and one of the point
things we have to share is that any
proceeds that might come from PI data
events - you know continues to are used
to continue to support our projects so
anytime you attend a conference or make
a donation that money will be used for
things like small development grants
financial services legal services
operational help promotional support and
and a whole wide range of things that we
do for these projects because we know
these open source tools they we all use
them but they take time and effort and
dedication from volunteers that
contribute to them and the support to
them focus them focus provides us a way
to support those projects that enable
them to you know let them focus on what
they do best which is continuing to
develop and contribute to these projects
to make them better so you know I always
like to first say you know thank you to
everyone for joining these meetups
organizing you know particular things to
the organizers and volunteers that
helped put on these community events any
type of contributions go a long way in
supporting
our mission and like I said I'm bummed I
won't be able to see you in person this
year but if you have any questions or
you're interested in getting involved in
addition to potentially reaching out to
the Berlin meetup organizers you can
always email me directly and my email
address is Jim Adam focused at org or
you can email admin at PI data org and
we'd love to have you and get you
involved and like I said we're always
looking for volunteers or other ways to
have people get involved so here's just
a few ways you can participate in a
local meetup which everyone here is
doing so already off to a great start
thank you you know and these meetups
helps share ideas we can learn from one
another and just give people an idea of
what they can take back to their work
and continue to improve and figure out
ways we can even improve the tools and
help support them you can attend a PI
data conference like I said money from
every PI data ticket sale is a donation
focused to continue our mission or even
volunteer our organizers can probably
have more than enough to say about some
of the work that the volunteers do at
the different conferences to make sure
that they happen able I would encourage
you don't maybe consider making a
donation or getting your company to
either sponsor a PI data then or the
focus itself has a corporate donation
program that would be happy to talk to
about as well and so we're always
looking to partner with corporations
because corporations often use and make
money off of these open-source tools so
if there is a way that they're able to
give just a little bit back to the
open-source community that that can go a
long way and so like I said any
questions any more information I'm happy
to kind of open up conversation or talk
more and you can either visit our
website then focus that'll work or email
me or admin org listed there and thank
you so that's what I have
thank you very much for the kind
introduce and how high day to fit and
now from the micro let's go to our micro
high data please yeah okay can everyone
hear me yes okay so I would like to
first ask to people who are currently
involve like through some two interviews
with people involved in the PI data that
in Chapter so like to give you an idea
of who we are and also maybe maybe join
us or maybe create your own whenever you
are so first do we have Valentina
oh yes yes great so I have like a really
simple question so first hi Valentina
can you tell me a bit quickly what you
are working on right now so what are you
doing
basically yeah so right now I am a
software Quality Assurance engineer I
studied astrophysics and I am still an
aspiring leader scientist
so yeah I would like to be the scientist
I'm programming quite a lot also in my
roles mm-hmm yeah so now can you tell me
how and why you become involved in the
organization of data yes so that's
because when I I terminated my PhD I
went to industry I didn't have any
experience in industry and I have been
interested in data science since that
like about what is seven years ago so I
started I found out that meetup was the
best place to
actually learn about industry people
networking jobs all these things that I
never heard about report and I started
going to the PI data meet up as well and
then I was I was really happy I remember
I don't know if it was like four four
years ago I maybe that I I joined the
call for volunteer for the conference
and I had a very beautiful experience
and so the year after when I was asked
to join the committee I was I gladly
accepted the invitation and and I'm
mostly now I'm mostly in the conference
coordinating the volunteers but yeah
since I've been in that role it really
feeds me and I it's also to give back to
the community because I have been
learning quite a lot great so far
last last one what's your favorite place
in building so during this current at
time you have a favorite talk or
restaurants to go to for all the I don't
have a real favorite place I'm actually
going by bike Allah is not my it was not
my thing I haven't taken the bike since
years and outside the lane going
everywhere by bike mostly also because
I'm looking for a new flat I'm going
probably here in there just today I went
somewhere and I'm back and then continue
working and but also since not so long
ago some of my favorite restaurants
again I've been also going there there
is one on the corner is Italian and
I'm from Sicily
No so yeah these are the places like
bike rides parks and my favorite
restaurant
not that much definitely biking and
sunlight burning is really cool I agree
okay
so thank you very much Valentina I will
just ask the second one hadron are you
here can you unmute yourself yes perfect
Hey so no surprise a dream can you
welcome can you tell me what you are
working on right now please
finding a job is one otherwise I I work
mostly on circuit land and otherwise
sometimes I which is a fairness and
machine learning initiated by Marcus ah
yeah great that's that's good and so can
you tell me why you decided to join and
to be involved in pi data
I was I was just looking for a bunch of
cool people really I moved to Berlin
four years ago and started immediately
going to meetups like move move to
Berlin open the meetup app it was like
okay where can I meet people and then
among them were a bunch of technical
meetups I used to go to a lot of them
and are all the ones that I went to play
Dido was the friendliest with like a
bunch of really nice organizers and then
we ended up being connected and started
working on the meetups and the
conference cool and that's one favorite
place in Berlin so during corona time or
ice cream diva
for you maybe I've been going to a bunch
of parks around in the car but otherwise
if if if it's an evening if it's close
to the weekend I'm out I'm probably in
15 different places when the bars impose
were not open just going from static to
schmitty and now you can actually spend
time there and that's usually where I am
cool great okay thank you very much a
dream thank you I think that's it I
would just so I was the first trial that
we did so please tell us in the comments
if you think that was interesting if you
have any suggestion that they are
welcome that we can do doing the breaks
that you're interested in otherwise
let's go for the second talk and I will
give back the talk to Matty there we go
thank you
yeah okay I hope that I hope that break
sort of keeps some more insight into who
we are if you have any questions post
them on
chat room on YouTube I will try to
answer them as best we can and also if
you think that you are the farthest away
from burping from all the participants
then write that in the chat as well we
will send some stickers to the to the
participant who was the furthest away
from Berlin I think currently the
Philippines is Israel okay and so with
that I give the floor to our second
speaker Andres thank you go ahead I'll
share the screen that first one second
okay okay so just everybody is it sit
okay are you saying my presentation now
yes I'm seeing it yes you don't see your
presentation okay perfect so first of
all hello and thank you for being here
for a very very short introduction of
myself I studied architecture now I'm
currently doing a master's in project
management and data science here in
Berlin I didn't do much of architecture
I started a software company then
another one and now it worked as the CTO
in a Latin American company is dedicated
to providing tools for closing the
gender gaps in the workplace through
technology and data that was a very
brief explanation of who I am and let's
get started with this so some
expectation management first my talk is
going to be more theoretical and it's
gonna and the main aim is to introduce
you all to the main concepts processes
and techniques behind the prime serious
analysis and furgus
so the agenda for today is first to have
a you have a look of what we know so far
then take a look into what make time
series so special
and finally short overview or of how to
handle such thing so let's get started
and when we are in the non planned
serious world and we're dealing with
cross-sectional data there is a very big
assumption there is a population from
which we're taking a random sample and
from this random sample we can make some
assumptions so we have many observations
of the same variables through time and
these observations are independent from
each other so for example here the
student one grade should be independent
from the student ten grade or age these
observations are generally taken at the
same point in time this means the same
year the same period or to be more
precise time here is not relevant at all
and we assume from the statistical
theory that these random variables
follow a certain distribution which
gives us some kind of explanation of
what we can expect so we do some
measurements we can somehow interpolate
the data and we can understand oh sorry
one second and we can make some
assumptions about what is happening in
the rest of the curve in the world of
thank serious
the first main difference is that there
is not such thing as a population here
what we have is different samples of the
same process through time and this gives
us at the end of the street series or
sequence of data points these have been
taken in a regular constant interval and
hence the target variable Y its index Y
time time of course being an independent
variable of which we have no control
these all leads to something very
important in fact here is that there is
an underlying structure in this case we
do care about the order of the death if
you remember the last example it doesn't
matter which student we mesh
first at the end we get the same data
set and we don't hear here the
underlying structure is very important
and we need to maintain it so this is
going to be one of the directives of
time series finally they put everything
that we do was a prediction meaning
forecasting looking into the future is
going to be an extrapolation of our data
so this means there's some uncertainty
on what we're doing or to be more
precise there's more uncertainty or what
on what we're doing in a very simplified
way our target variable is a function of
time this just means that knowing the
time in we can go backwards and know
exactly which is going to be our value
this is a simple case this is the energy
consumption of the United States so if I
tell you a date you can go with the
function of time and understand exactly
how much was the demand a more important
concept of time series is that sometime
you will hear that the time series is an
s2 casting process what this means in
more simple words is that we have in our
case we are saying our data represents
one possible outcome of many but since
we cannot go back in time and run the
process many times as that stochastic
processes implied meaning that all these
different runs come from the same
process but there are like parallel
things that happen we don't do that it's
not realistic to think that we can go to
every single point in time and have all
the possible observations so this one
will never happen because if you think
it through the theory what happens in
mr. casting processes is when you run
many many times the same process through
time you end up with something like we
saw before you have a distribution and
these facts have add even more
uncertainty to time series analysis and
this is why for example we have concerts
as stationarity the stationarity in the
practical way is saying that the mean
and the variance of a data set meaning
the statistical properties they don't
change through time or they don't they
do not change systematically through
trying to be more precise for example
here you can see that this is non
stationary because as far as you go to
time the mean is going up and the
variance is every time
more on the other hand here we can see a
stationary series and it doesn't matter
when you take the measures you're gonna
have roughly the same measures of mean
and variance and this is what we
understand as the stationarity or
weakest stationarity to be more precise
stationarity is very important mainly
because most of the models we're going
to use in time series assume that your
data is stationary so it is not you will
have to do some kind of operations on
your data to make it a stationary there
are many ways to do it for example you
can take the logarithm of your data and
that will sterilize the variance or you
can use differencing that is just
looking at the difference between points
and other points themselves and this
also helps towards taking your data
towards stationarity of course you have
the statistical tests that will tell you
if that is easier or not but mainly you
can see from thank you so here visual
inspection is already a quite a good
place to start and other characteristics
and attributes of time series the level
the level is nothing else than the mean
of our overall data set the trend the
trend is long-term increase or decrease
in the data and is not necessarily
linear I think most of us are now
familiar with the coronaviruses
financial growth this is also a trend
but it's just not linear seasonality may
be one of the most important things that
we will talk about today and this is a
pattern that repeats you'll say it
repeats itself over time and it's when
the variable is affected by a seasonal
factor systems in this case were not
precisely meaning winter summer but the
seasons is more something regarding time
so there's a causal relationship between
the measure you have and the point in
time that you take it yeah and of course
what is important is that there is a
known frequency and it's the same it can
be anything from years to minutes but
it's repeated and repeated again cycles
are similar but in here you have the
property that you don't know the
frequency and normally we will see that
the trend and the cycles are going to be
integrated in one variable that is
called the trend cycle or cycle trend
it just shows the overall movement of
your series and finally the white noise
as it's known in France furious is just
all the information that you ten series
have that is not explainable that is
caused by chance form or randomness it's
supposed to be normally distributed this
means that we if we explore all the
possible values you will have something
like this and so going back to
seasonality how decision at seasonality
look like so for example here in our
example we have the again the
consumption energy consumption through
the years of the United States and you
can clearly see that there's a pattern
that repeats itself through time so this
year and their year and the year and the
year this is called a yearly seasonality
but you can also see it for example if
you look at the same data in a zoomed
way the same thing happens this is the
day of it so from 0 hours to 24 hours
and you can see that every day something
similar happens these also is the
seasonal pattern but in this case we
have daily seasonality this is why it's
so important to know what is the measure
of your data the units that you're
dealing with so because sometimes you
will get in good years sometimes you
will be dealing with microseconds and
most of the time it is important to
analyze the time series from the
perspective of each one of these
components that we just talked about and
in order to do so we do something called
the composition process there to do to
do these what we assume is that our time
series is a model that is the sum or the
multiplication of the three factors that
we already saw so you can either add the
trend the seasonality and the residuals
or multiply it in other kind of models
and this will give you something like
this so you have a trend the seasonality
and the residuals made you add them up
you should you should reproduce your
death there are other kinds of the
compositions for example with Fourier
turns that is more the sinus and cosinus
but this is a little bit more
complicated for the story and of course
the multiplicative one thanks to the
logarithm and these properties you can
take the logarithm and just treat it as
an attitude series so this is going to
be here also an import
tool to having toolbox remember that
what noise we talked about is the same
as saying residuals is the same term
this is interchangeable in time series
most of the time another thing that is
important in kind series is that instead
of looking for correlation with other
variables as we're used to we're going
to look of correlations with the
variable itself just backwards in time
and this is known as autocorrelation
because you're correlating the variable
with itself and how does it how does
this work
let's say for the example that this is
our point zero in time meaning the last
measure we took of the demand and we're
going to look what is the correlation
between now and one unit back in time
and of course you have to repeat this
process zero with one one we to to
retreat like going one step back and you
will get something like this the scatter
plot I will show you what is the
correlation and you see that for in this
particular example whatever the
consumption or the demand was now it's
very likely to be the same that it's
going to be in the next unit of time so
there's a very strong correlation also
in the case of demand of energy
consumption if you look 24 units of time
in the past in our case our early data
so if you look 24 hours in the past it's
very probable that the consumption is
going to be the same because the
conditions are the same the weather the
time of the day people use that work or
not and you can also see that there's a
certain correlation so this is what is
known as autocorrelation in time series
from these same principle we we
developed what is called BlackBerry's
and lag is nothing else than a period of
time between one event and another and
in our more precise example it means
that you can engineer features by
looking back into time so let's use
again our example where we're standing
here in time this is our last measure
and we need to engineer features are
like what was happening to our before
and what was happening 24 hours ago so
to build this data set we're just going
to shift one up and take the value we're
going to ship 24 times or data set and
how can you value and these here is our
new data set do you think it true these
two engineering features come from this
just through
into the past and this is also very
important and very particular to time
series if you remember correctly
normally your thought the correlation
between predictors is not a good thing
but in these cases precisely what we
want regarding that exploration we have
many like very particular visuals to
time series the first one being the time
plot that we were so many times and what
are the axes here you have time and
whatever is your dependent variable
again this reminds us of the Y being a
function of time also you have this kind
of plot but it's very interesting and
gives you a lot of insights but it's
called the seasonal plot in this case
Briggs in this particular case sorry
we're looking at the day from the zero
hour to 24 hour but we want to see how
it looks that same day through the whole
year in each of the months
so this is one day like the average of
all days of January of December sorry
this is the average of all the days in
January etcetera etc etc so this gives
you a very good explanation and a very
good overview for how similar things
happen and how similar things are across
different aggregation functions in these
particular case you can see that the
curve of demand is pretty much the same
during the whole year there's only a
slight trend in this case the trend is
that it goes ah to December and then it
goes back to me this is of course linked
to the seasons winter and summer and
that's why also where the words is now
if you come from there is a causal
relationship between the measure and the
time of the year it was take another
kind of way of saying this is also
seasonal plotted from sub-series
is this one and in this example we're
seeing the aggregated data for January
all the aggregated data of January for
the year 2016 the year 2000 17 18 19 and
this gives you a very clear overview of
what happens over the years because you
can see also that for example here May
is the one with the lowest consumption
in general this is the mean and December
is the one with the highest consumption
in general and with this to me so this
is also a very useful tool and you can
see of course the pattern
a year that is also kind of very clear
here and scatterplots
as we saw before it's also true that we
will use a lot but and the only
difference here is that the scatterplot
is not between our variable and another
one but the terrible at itself in the
past so here we can see three examples
again energy demand is the example here
you have now and now related to -1 or in
this case plus 1 because that's how the
tightened and packaged plot sit and you
also have 24 hours ago and 10 hours ago
if you think it true in our example of
demand is very logical because of course
the consumption now is very very likely
to be the same or similar to the one in
1 hour ahead and it's also to say likely
to be the same one as 24 hours ago but
doesn't have any relationship with 10
hours in the future is there's no clear
relationship there after talking about
the same correlation these may be the
two most important tools that we need to
understand and can really get a grip off
towards returning to the time series I
will first explain the axis the axis X
is the steps in your data so this will
vary depending on the data you have in
my case and in this example I have
hourly data so every one of this means
one hour into the past and this here in
this axis is just a normal period
Pearson correlation coefficient so this
graph will always a start in zero
meaning the present and he was they
would start doing correlations to one
value back in time to others back in
time tree by this packing time etc if we
look at it more and more particularly
example is the same as saying like I'm
going to stand here and look 24 hours
back then I gonna start here do 24 hours
back and the same and these builds these
autocorrelation function because how how
this plot is made is that you have your
data set and you just shift it one unit
and then do a person correlation between
these two variables the partial
autocorrelation function is a little bit
more complicated but what it means is
that it shows you the direct effect that
the lag has on your today variable
meaning that in the autocorrelation
function whatever happens here has a
relationship that goes like this you
know like it's like a chain reaction but
in the person of the correlations you
are directly looking like you are making
big jobs between what's happening now
and what is happening at 24 hours ago
etc so it's the same principle but just
done differently and how do you produce
this you do a linear regression with all
the lag variables and then the
coefficients the because of your linear
regressions are going to be what you
plot on the y-axis just before
continuing and my example we know that
energy consumption is very similar 24
hours ago
and we can see that very clearly here
when you go 24 steps back in kind you
can see there there's a very high
correlation the same here this is still
significant between now and 24 hours and
also you can see that the first one is
very correlated and you can see them
both plots this is a little bit of
residual so that's why we use both
floats at the same time to know exactly
which lakhs to we should use in our
models regarding data preparations there
are some things to that has to be taken
into consideration first of all the tree
is rule as we know it doesn't work in
those cases because here outliers may
carry information something may have
happened at this moment in time and for
example here you think it true
it kinds of respond with a certain
pattern that we're looking into the into
the data so take just plainly taking it
out because the trees rule doesn't make
a lot of sense what can you do for the
simplest model here is to use the moving
average and you this is a rough
estimation of what it would be and if
you look at thoroughly you see that this
would be included at a moving average so
it will be a mistake to use the trees
roots memory there are some more
advanced methodologies for example the
ones that Facebook profit package uses
to do a normal in addition but in simple
words anomaly detection is to identify
patterns and if something is
significantly off of this pattern it is
going to be considered an outlier
as always expert knowledge is very
important here for example the World Cup
you may have this can be the World Cup
and the
something went up like crazy but it's
just one point in time so this one you
can really take it out of this data set
because it's not important
another thing to take into consideration
is that missing values they cannot exist
in our data so we necessarily need to do
something with them we need to impute
them there are many ways to do it the
more the simpler one will be to use the
mean or a silver value but of course
this will depend on a specific case that
you have another more like more used
approach is to interpolate the data and
this is just drawing the closest limit
with these points of course you can also
do the last observation can be forward
that will be take this point in time and
like this or you can use something more
advanced like a an and mice whatever
other technology that you want to use of
course these ones you need a
multivariate data set for spinning with
your own that I said it's not that easy
hey I'm gonna answer the question now I
think it's a good question give me one
second so the thing as I said before the
missing values are forbidden because
precisely here the structure is so
important and there's an underlying
thing happening so if you think it true
time doesn't stop because you don't have
one measure it doesn't mean that that
day or that hour
didn't existed so when you take out that
value you are destroying the time
structure behind it which in
cross-sectional data it doesn't really
matter because if you have one row less
is just you can assume the rest of the
of the shape as we discussed before so
here is very important to maintain
always the time structure so if you have
minutes you need to have every possible
minutes of course there's a logical
constraints you can know it go to
milliseconds but you will try to feel
the whole data set of course inside the
same units that you are already happy
another consideration and I think this
is maybe the most important one is
regarding the splitting of the data sets
test for tests and training the golden
rule here is you cannot look into the
future
hence the sample must not be random
because if you think if you think again
about the example of the students you
don't really care what what roles do you
get at the end it's even better the more
random you do it the more certain you
can be that your predictions are all
right in that any times you're sorry if
you look into the future your cuts
you're somehow cheating so you need you
really need to be sure that your split
is time-based meaning only looking to
the past
it should also include full seasons or
cycles for the seasonality if you don't
include the whole cycle of the
seasonality the models can not
understand what's happening and this is
another important thing they have at
least to have the length of the longest
lag what do I mean with this if my model
for example depends on the 24 lack these
means that I depend on what happened 20
hours 24 hours ago I need to have at
least twenty four data points to predict
this is a very absurd case because of
course I have more than 24 data points
but when you're talking for example
about data sets that have years it's not
that obvious so yes maybe you have a
very nice correlation between three
years ago but what happens if you have
only 10 30 30 30 points in time so this
is just good fit against consideration
and for my point of view it's also
should be logic easier for humans to
understand because machines they don't
care and for them time means nothing but
for us it's better if you cut in precise
font meaning for example the first of
January or the full year a month and not
caught in the middle like fifteen or
fourteen of May because maybe for the
machine it doesn't make any difference
but for you is going to be harder to
interpret a true feature engineering as
we discussed before we can divide a lot
of things from the time index meaning
the time in which the measures were
taken you can have a lot of nominal
values for example month it can be
encoded from 1 to 12 today from 131
hours to 1 to 24 etcetera a day of the
week and you can also have dummy
variables for something like is month
start or is leap year which in cases of
business in business problems it can be
something that is relevant for your
particular
case also you can engineer the demand
blacks that we talked before and this
can be simple ones for example like one
can be what happened 24 hours ago or
like for what happened 14 days ago but
you can also do rolling average of what
happened in the last week so you take
the whole last week and you make a
moving and moving error a rolling
average sorry and you keep doing this
average and this produces a new data
point in your data set and something to
get take into consideration when you add
extra genus variables meaning you have
your variable and for example being
consumption of electricity you are the
weather which is known to be a good
explanation variable you have to take
care with these cases that about what is
called a spurious correlations meaning
that there's a depend dependency to time
but not a dependency to your variable a
very simple and clear example of this is
the size of the tree and the population
size of the country they don't really
have any causal relationship between
them but if you look through time both
they tend to grow so you can be fooled
by this and now we're getting something
more down-to-earth and practical
modeling and forecasting so first first
of all and this simpler simplest way
sorry to tackle this problem is just to
use a normal multiple regression to do
so the first thing is to completely
disregard the time index we're not going
to care about it anymore of course this
is after train and test this please
because there will really need the time
index and if you look it through if you
look it closely you have a target
variable and you have features and
predictors so this is just a normal that
I said like the ones you're used to to
do with machine learning so this is one
of the approaches that you can use as a
baseline of course there are baselines
model there are simpler and more related
to time series the simplest one being
the simple name they are a cold knife
because they make very simple
assumptions the first one but it says
here this kind of this equation is
formalized that the value of tomorrow
it's going to be the same value of today
so an example would be if I sold today
five ice creams I'm gonna assume that
tomorrow
we'll sell also 5's ice creams and then
I'm tomorrow and actually I saw the
eight ice cream
so the next day I'm gonna say I'm gonna
sell eight ice groups again and so on
and so on and so on the trend naive is
very similar to this one but you add a
little bit of the drift towards
increasing or decreasing for example if
your business is growing then do you
know that maybe today I sold eight ice
creams but tomorrow is going to be nine
and ten eleven but there's a particular
trend that you can in fear from your
data and you would do it by looking at
the past so you can clearly see how the
things it's easy balding and finally the
seasonal diet is the same as saying okay
to the base sundae and I know that
whatever I sell every Sunday is what
I've Brazil the next one so I just
looking to the death of 27 days ago and
this is my assumption for the next day
if you come to a little bit of more
complex models we have to first remember
what is a simple regression we have our
predictor or predictive value and this
is going to be equal to some intercept
plus a coefficient time or input
variable yeah so if we translate this
principle to time series we have two
models which are the basis of most of
time series forecasting
we first have the auto regressive model
which is normally seen as a R P P is
just the order of the model that we will
understand shortly what it means and we
have the moving average model or in a
order QQ also is what kind of model
we're using because this is a family of
models the auto regressive is nothing
else than doing a simple regression of
our variable but looking into the lag
variables so for example an AR 1 model
would be my YT is equal to a constant
exactly like here boss but plus sorem
coefficient multiplying my lag valuable
in my like value in one time in the past
of course there's always some kind of
error in our predictions and this is
incorporated in both models and this is
going to be there no matter what because
there's some randomness what's happening
and we are the
autoregressive is just a simple linear
regression on the like values on the
other hand the moving average one is the
simpler linear regression but not on the
BlackBerry nose but on the error of your
past predictions so for example
yesterday I predicted that I was going
to sell 10 ice creams but I actually
sold eight so I have an error of two
measures of the units that I didn't
understood so those two units I'm going
to put them into my machine on this
model and they're gonna help me
understand what's gonna happen next next
this is called a moving average because
normally you are for example a always
sell ten ice creams that's my average
this is what kind of what I know and
basing myself on the errors I make every
day I'm gonna try to adjust around this
average to see how much I'm gonna
actually sell the next day and then we
have the armor and oedema fabulous that
maybe you heard of if you have been
looking into time serious analysis this
is something that I'm sure will come up
and the armour is nothing else that
combining the past models we saw so is
the same as saying AR model plus ma
model together in this example an ARMA 1
comma 0 model is the same as thing AR
one because the MA part has zero order
mean that we don't take care of any
error we don't care the same goes for an
ARMA 1 as 0 1 would be the same as a non
a moving average of order 1 yeah so this
is just an addition of the literal
addition of these two roles
ARIMA on the other hand it adds
something else that we haven't seen
before and it's this little eye in the
middle or which is represented by d this
is called ways that integrate is the
auto regressive integrated moving
average the eye of integration what it
does is to do a differentiation of our
time series if you remember I said that
one of the main assumptions made by the
models is that the devices fashion error
so it's not you must do something in
order to use any of these models so you
can do it yourself with the logarithm of
the depreciation but also the edema mode
it helps you and do it through it during
the process so you can have an edema
that has an auto regressive
and one as differentiation factor so
that means that we're going to
differentiate one time your data and
then run the a or model so this is what
they are email stands for and here we
just start adding letters to our model
and the S of Salima is the same but it
it has into consideration a seasonal
component meaning is like kind of the
same as saying that we have two además
so this is the ARIMA that we already
know and we're just doing it we're doing
this process twice so one in the cloves
fast and the other one is looking back a
certain amount of time so for example as
that email model with the seasonal
component of 22 of 24 will be like I
have an arena and then I look again into
the 24 lakh and I do another in order
like in the past it's a little
complicated but just think about it to
doing two times the same thing
and finally sorry max is the same but we
add an additional layer of complexity
which is the exogenous variables for
example the weather as I thought before
so this is the oedema family this is I
think one of the most common models to
predict time series and this is the
definition of differentiation so you
just take the value of before to the
value of today and what you end up with
is the series of differences and finally
I'm going to talk about recurrent neural
networks but I'm not gonna go into any
detail because this is a talk by itself
and you know that from language
processing that but it will tell us the
order of the words meaning the order of
our sequence does matter is not the same
to say and a human that's saying human
eye so the same idea was transferred
from the processing language processing
world into the time series one because
if you think it true you have a series
of things of axis or inputs that matter
the order in which you understand them
and you have some some sort of
prediction so for this they mostly you
will see people using long short long
short term memory recurrent neural
networks or what is called the group
gated recurrent units which are kind of
similar in the principle of course I've
also seen some people using
convolutional there were there were
convolutional neural networks or you can
also use
normal deep network to do a multiple
regression this is another option but I
think is a little bit over overdoing it
and this is how a modeling pipeline
could look like so you can decide which
is your baseline can be one of the
naives and one of the multiple linear
regressions and of course if you cannot
do better than this or significantly
better than this then just continue and
do something else because that's not it
doesn't make any sense to add such
complexity to go all the way here you're
not gonna get a significant improvement
finally how do we how do we evaluate and
there's a very important concept that it
doesn't come up in other domains that is
the walk forward first of all we need to
define what is an error because the
calculation is simple observed minus
forecast but these always have to have a
business name in the case again of
consumption of energy what is worse for
your company is it worse that you over
produced energy or that you lacked that
you don't have enough energy for the
city
so these idea of what we're what the
direction of the error means for my
business is very important and is
something you have you should have T
here from the beginning and metrics we
have the same ones that we normally used
I mean absolute error that is a very
good business metric that means where
error that is good for algorithms
because it's very fast to calculate the
route means wherever that is kind of the
same but is good for us because it's
more down-to-earth it's very very very
sensitive to extreme error so it's good
and finally but not least we have
something called the akaike information
criterion this is just measure that
would tell you how parsimonious is your
home and this is good to know because
for example for the atom the regression
of the regression models if you remember
correctly the graphs of the PCF there
are a lot of flags that you could use
because they are significant but of
course these are correct information
criteria is gonna tell you how many of
them it is necessary for your model to
be accurate enough so at the end what
this does is uses the likelihood of the
model
your data so how good the data fits
their knowledge and it has a penalty for
each predictor that you use so the more
predictor you use the more penalty pens
the AC the law is the one that you will
look for when you're trying to assess
the different models regarding the
residual analysis as we talked before
there's something very important here
that is the forecast error and we wanted
when we want to see at the end of our
forecasting is that there is nothing
left only white noise because by
definition if we only see white noise
there is no more information left in
your data this is completely random so
we can now explain just one topic left
because I am running out of time and if
you do a simple in sample forecast
meaning you look back in time your model
is going to do a quite good job to
interpret your data you can almost not
see the blue line because they're
practically the same but if you try to
do the same looking into the future
these kinds of things can happen the
data can diverge completely going crazy
it can convert compared to the mean or
to some value but in general you will
start having a bigger and bigger and
bigger error why does this happen it
happens because if we look at this
example very quickly and let's assume
this is x u and we are studying here
yeah and we know that our model is going
to be one step in a back in time to step
back in time and 24 hours back in time
so so we have this will I look at the
lack one like two and like 24 this is
what I used to predict something and
each step I do I have to look at desires
so if you look if you see detail here
from the second prediction I am NOT
already using my own prediction as a
predictor for the set for the next step
and this of course adds up and there's a
moment where you are making predictions
only based on prediction so of course
there's a lot of uncertainty a lot of
error that is adding up and it's making
your predictions go crazy this is why we
have to retrain we train and retrain on
what we call a moving rolling window the
principle here is that you do like this
you use this data to train your model
and you predict whatever
window of time you need what is the size
of this window it will depend completely
on the business you're in and in your
not only the business world
go so this has to be defined from the
beginning what is going to be my window
of predictions in the case of energy
consumption we cared about 24 hours in
the future because it's what you have to
pre produce or kind of negotiate with
the energy producers and these you start
moving into time so every time you
predict then you move and with the real
values you retrain your model and Yuri
predict the next step well and finally
you can use the same logic but with an
adjusted roll it window of course this
one is a lot better because you have
more historical data that we all know
that it's better for predicting but it
has this has a downside is that of
course you will need more and more and
more computing power so it depends on
your ability isn't that in that
department and finally this is what a
time series pipeline could look like so
yeah and I'm going to do the collecting
I extended myself too much but I'll
share the slides there is some more
entities interested and thank you very
much thank you indeed I'm gonna
virtually clap I don't I don't know if
anyone can see or hear that but there we
go so questions I think I'm gonna let
the because the YouTube stream is a
little bit behind this little lag um so
I'm gonna let that catch up and and ask
question in between so there's a the
first question already and can this also
be used for ezg analysis or
electrocardiogram analysis I'm not
entirely sure if that's referring to the
time series analysis in general or
specific slide I would say yes because
these time series like universe is
mainly focused on signal processing so
one of the one of the biggest
applications is for processing of these
signals and electrocardiograms I can
imagine F as far as my understanding in
eg goes it's a constant
know that you couldn't start either
dividing patterns and maybe even predict
if someone's going to have a heart
attack but I don't know it from
experience I'm just saying that I think
it's possible
it fits the criteria okay I was
wondering I was quite interested in what
you said about the time series analysis
field borrowing ideas from from NLP
enter in the sequence modeling area and
I was wondering if you have anything to
say about the recent development in NLP
where the sequence models like LST M's
and the gated recurrent units are going
out of fashion and the more kind of
structural neural networks like to
transform amoral like bird and gbt to
are very much starting to be the focus
of research efforts and there's some
evidence also that those capture sort of
linguistic syntactic semantic structure
in a in in a way that is kind of
linguistically reasonable I don't know
what the equivalent of that would be on
time series analysis or if those models
are being applied I was just wondering
do be very honest I I don't I don't know
it by personal experience I've seen some
talks about the transformer one the
transformer mudball I don't know much of
it I can imagine that for 10 series data
because of the structure is just one so
you care about the order but the order
is just one it's not the same as for
language processing because there are
many different orders can come into the
machine and you need to understand out
of context which road to take but I
think people using the transformer to
predict okay very good
mmm can you recommend the TSA a book
with a focus in Python yes
put in the last slide English I'm gonna
put it I'm going to put the tool
recommend it babe with bibliographies at
least just to start with I'm serious
the first one is in art but at least for
me it was a good Bible to start with
this because it has everything and it's
very well explained and it's not in
Python which I would love to but for the
conceptual part I think it's very very
good and then the second one that I'm
sharing here in the comments it is
mainly for Python it has a chapter for
time series this are both open source
and you can access them online
okay maybe make sure if you can post the
two links the two texts also to the
YouTube channels but we get them there
as well
yeah sure okay any any other questions
that maybe if you're speaking you are
muted yeah there is another YouTube
question whether it's always a good idea
normalizing the forecast of data before
giving them to Naga weapon
unless did you did you hear the question
no is it always a good idea to normalize
forecast data before giving them to two
algorithms that depends on which one
you're gonna use I would say that the
more traditional ones they don't care
but of course if you're gonna if you're
going to use any kind of neural network
it's better to at least scale them you
can also use the log transformation to
normalize the to stabilize the variance
but it depends I think the answer really
depends on which one you use and the
kind of data you have okay do you have
any thoughts about automatic
timeseriesforecasting package is like
Crawford but you mentioned that in your
presentation as well I think profit is a
very comprehensive package so for time
series analysis in Python is that it's a
most very well documented and it has
almost everything you can meet some very
advanced things for example the anomaly
detection it can be done automatically
with the profit package and or the
concept will learn her so I think it's
it's nice to first do it by hand and
then use the package like that but yes
it's very good like for practical
reasons another question from YouTube
have you ever needed to perform the ADF
test for I don't know how to read that D
minus two TS data integrated more twice
integrated more than twice I guess no
not in my case but I know it's not is
not which is not uncommon to integrate
more than once to differentiate more
than once I think the question was about
integrating more than more than twice
then I in my experience don't but I I
cannot know depends again of the data
but I
no but I would risk that my answer would
be like because we have the AIC
criterion if you integrate that much
plus the hair plus the AR coefficient of
the aiming coefficient you may you may
broke what it what is called the person
Moniz rule but it's not supposed to sum
up more than six all the terms that you
use in your study or whatever model you
should have more not more than six so
you have already an AR for plus a one
order of MA doing tree integrations it
will be too much and of course like you
know any other fields the more
parsimonious the better yeah
and so Allen here on the room is asking
one more thing have you used Kalman
filters before testing are you gonna
make these slides available yeah of
course it's a Google presentation I have
to make it public then I will share the
link yeah okay awesome well then I think
we are through with questions unless we
can you have a one final one from
YouTube nothing
okay well then thank you very much
unless that was a thousand very good
introductory talk to a time series
analysis and that's it for the June
meetup as well thank you everyone for
joining we don't know if we if the July
meetup is going to also be virtual or in
person if it is in person I think we'll
try to maintain the YouTube live stream
we'll have to see how we can accommodate
that but if that's possible then we'll
definitely keep that up but yeah other
than that thank you everyone for for
joining for the interest and I don't
know see you next time
thank you very much
[Music]